Patrick thalwell 23 year old has been
found guilty at York magistrates Court
of threatening behavior and it happened
back in November because he threw at
least five eggs at the king so Patrick
felwell a 23 year old he's been found
guilty at York magistrates court and
he's been found guilty of threatening
behavior and that was after he was
throwing at least five eggs at the king
it happened in November last year there
you go that's what you're looking at the
9th of November so at least five eggs
he held those eggs towards the king and
the queen concert Camilla was there as
well they it was it happened as they
arrived at Michael gate bar all five of
the eggs missed as you can see
um and there he is he's a student
and he pleaded not guilty to threatening
behavior but
um
he was just found guilty of threatening
behavior after throwing at least five
eggs at the king during a walkabout in
York in November last year let's have a
look now at those pictures from the 9th
of November that was uh Patrick just
arriving in court but yeah this was the
incident last year the ninth
yeah I seem to remember there was audio
on that
um but he so he held the eggs towards
the king and queen consort they were out
in York and they were making their way
to micklegate bar
on the night at least five who threw and
um they all missed
he then went on was arrested and was
found guilty just now 23 year old
student in York magistrates Court he
pleaded not guilty the charge was
threatening behavior after those eggs
were thrown
at King Charles during a visit to York
glass
to York
um I'm waiting because we do have a
shinki Mara Rica a correspondent he was
in the court and he can obviously bring
us a lot more detail but just to to give
you an update that the man you're
looking at is Patrick felwell he's a 23
year old student and on the 9th of
November last year he tried to throw
eggs at the king and the queen consort
Camilla when they were out doing their
Walkabout as they um really enjoy doing
actually so they were in York enjoying a
day out there and they were on their way
to What's called the Michael gate bar
and that was when Patrick felwell threw
five eggs at them or at least five exits
according to the court so he went on he
pleaded not guilty at York magistrates
Court
charge was threatening behavior but yeah
he has now been found guilty at York
Magistrate's court of threatening
behavior after throwing at least five
eggs at the king during a walkabout in
November last year we're trying to get
shingy up we're having some problems
with um his audio so as soon as we do
get shingy up we'll go back and find out
what happened in court what was said
there